for people who say suffer from kidney  disease or heart disease or high  cholesterol do those people have to be  worried switching on to something that's  animal based no you don't and so there's  this huge misconception in the medical  community that a diet high in protein is  bad for your kidneys there's no research  there's definitely no controlled  research that shows that a high protein  diet protein from any sort is bad for  the human kidneys people with any  medical condition you're still a human  being therefore you need to eat a human  specific diet a proper human diet and  for every human on the planet a proper  human diet consists of a large  percentage of fatty meat